look it's like this if you take
Apocalypse Now and sprinkle in a little
Gemini man you will get something that
resembles metal gear I don't know what
you want to do with that information
welcome to my brain
[Music]
Gemini man so Gemini man's a movie
starring Will Smith and The Fresh Prince
Will Smith is a sniper he's a hit man
now he's retired and now this agency is
coming after him sending him their best
which is a Will Smith clone so Will
Smith's basically taking on his younger
self so I'm gonna said was what I liked
about the movie but I liked about the
movie was the supporting cast and Will
Smith Mary Elizabeth Winstead and
Benedict Wong I felt worked really well
with Will Smith rated what they're there
for and this really comes across in the
movie no matter how much you do like
them they're there so Will Smith's
character has someone to talk to
while he's on the run and what comes
with that they have to talk and so now
that's how you're getting exposition
otherwise it'd just be Will Smith being
very strong silent type trying to figure
it out so it's best that they're in it I
especially like Benedict Wong because I
think Benedict Wong actually he has that
that low-key humor yeah dudes funny all
right let's get back to the let's get
back to the plot which is pretty boring
the plot is boring it's a pretty boring
plot because this is the plot this agent
is being hunted by another agent yeah
it's the plot of like 70,000 spy movies
or maybe you can see it like this this
agent is being hunted by another agent
who is trained by the guy who trained
the agent the plot is pretty you've seen
this plot a metric [ __ ] Tilian times
before there's nothing new here it's
like every spy movie with that plot
relies on a stick it relies on something
to be like yeah but this was the new
element so the new element is CGI young
Will Smith and they've been selling the
CGI hard I saw this one ad that was like
it's a game changer but it's not I mean
I'm not saying it's not impressive it is
impressive in parts most of those parts
being scenes at night a lot of dark
shadowy scenes which is a lot of scenes
with young Will Smith in this movie the
darker the scene the easier it is to
hide the flaws in CGI so yeah a lot of
dark scenes is one scene in particular
young Will Smith character he's actually
kind of intense and he's having an
argument and there was one shot where I
was like okay I couldn't tell that was
CGI that was actually really good it was
one shot like one syllable one word the
rest of it it's CGI you've seen before I
can't say he looks better than grand
moff tarkin did in rogue one because I
heard and I didn't actually look into
this [ __ ] I probably should have before
I started filming but based on the
finished product I believe it's not
actually the de-aging software it's
actually just motion
caPSURE it's the kind of technology
they've been doing for years which
doesn't look as good as the de-aging
software and had to have been a
licensing thing right there do you think
they were sitting around like crazy that
they don't have a technology a software
that's actually called de-aging software
since we want to da Jim it's crazy it's
like man if only that absolutely existed
which it absolutely does named for the
thing we actually specifically want to
do in this movie I know I'm not a CGI
expert I'm the first to say it but the
de-aging they do and the marvel movies
looks a lot better than the CGI in here
so all the boasting about this being a
game-changer I just don't see it so
there's a scene that takes place in the
daytime I was like took me back to Tron
Legacy I'm like that's a videogame
cutscene just not just in the facial
expression but how that character moves
to just move like a video game cutscene
I've seen some video game cutscenes I
think look more natural than the man I
will say in a purely technical aspect
when you're looking at the visual
quality and clarity of the film the
movie looks great which means it's
probably gonna look great in 4k when it
comes out I mean you could see that the
sweat the pores just on a human person
and even on CGI Will Smith if it was
just a snapshot of CGI Will Smith like a
picture a still frame would be like I I
can't tell that he's CGI it's when he
starts walking talking and moving then
it's like oh now I know kind of finish
this up in the end the plot of Gemini
man it's a pretty cliche applies by
being hunted by a spy and the agency he
once was affiliated with you have
whatever and the stick they rely on
which is hey look how good we are at CGI
isn't as good as I feel they thought it
was CGI in this movie it's like an
American Idol singer like not the really
terrible ones but the ones that you're
like you're not bad you're just not as
good as you think you are in the end I'm
just gonna say Gemini man I'm not gonna
remember in t-minus one day yep already
forgot disclaimer that little comparison
I made at the beginning of this video
that is no disrespect to Metal Gear
which is all right so Gemini man have
you seen it are you gonna see it or
what's your favorite movie about a spy
being hunted by a spy possibly by an
agency he was once affiliated with
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want
Seymour click right here to see more
[Music]